I major archaeological dig in Southern
California could rewrite the history
books until recently researchers
believed humans reached North America
15,000 years ago but new findings
published in the journal Nature suggest
there was human activity a hundred and
thirty thousand years ago scientists
believe these primitive beings came
between Neanderthals and archaic Homo
sapiens
Matea via al is that the San Diego
Natural History Museum at hey good
morning
well good morning it took more than 20
years to put together this very
complicated puzzle but in the end their
findings including this very large tusk
right here could rewrite and reshape how
we feel about human evolution highways
are an everyday part of life in Southern
California but it turns out humans may
have traveled here long before anyone
could have imagined as a paleontologist
so it's really amazing to have
discovered a site of such importance in
our own backyard this archaeological
shocker began in 1992 when scientists
from the San Diego Natural History
Museum uncover the bones of a mastodon
ten feet under a highway construction
site in a way is this is like a paleo
crime scene paleontologist Tom dem ra
was one of the first to arrive and
almost instantly knew they'd uncovered
something special the important
fractures are these fractures here see
how smooth and curved that is this is
the kind of fracture that's produced
from impact the team believes the heavy
femur bones could only be broken by a
human using a two-handed tool possibly
to extract marrow for food by
replicating the breaking patterns and
using state-of-the-art dating methods
the group concluded humans first reached
the Americas over a hundred and thirty
thousand years ago not 15,000 years ago
as previous research has suggested
there's room for skepticism for sure but
USC associate professor dr. Christian
Carlson wants more evidence one instance
is fascinating but I think we need to
find another site or two before we begin
to accept this I was a strong critic
when I first looked at this and I said
Mike I can't believe that this is really
here but but this is science our
geologist Stephen Hollen has spent most
of his career researching prehistoric
human existence and is ready to face
critics who aren't yet ready to rewrite
history
we're expecting pushback we expect
people to be critical we want people to
be critical what makes you so sure that
something else didn't break it over time
people have been doing these experiments
for years and say that only humans with
hammer stones can produce these kinds of
features well there are still a lot of
unanswered questions the president of
the museum joked yesterday that this is
just proof that even early humans wanted
to live here in San Diego
gaile okay well why not well a weather
was good weather it's very nice area
here Thank You Maria